[Music]
listen it's hard to maintain social
distancing anywhere but especially on an
airplane just thinking about it freaks
me out
recently United Airlines tried to
implement distancing by announcing that
they are quote automatically blocking
middle seats to give passengers enough
space on board but on May 9th a
passenger on board a United flight to
San Francisco from Newark tweeted out
this picture in which middle seats are
clearly occupied the tweet sparked
predictable backlash and prompted
demands to leave seats empty on
airplanes but as the number of daily
travelers slowly picks up again after
the unprecedented drop in March airlines
like United will find it harder and
harder to leave seats empty on their
flights
so all this debate over the middle seat
makes me wonder how far can an
infectious disease actually spread on an
airplane even if we block the middle
seat and if we do block that seat our
our ticket price is gonna go up I'm Cleo
Abram and this is answered five bucks
this is a visualization of the inside of
a Boeing 767 it shows how a single cough
can spread throughout a plane between
air filtration cycles when I call like
this you know it definitely generate
that had a lot of atomic that's
professor Yan Chen he helped create this
animation to study the ways infectious
diseases in cough droplets can spread to
other passengers due to the airflow
design in most commercial planes those
cough droplets are first carried upwards
and then travels sideways through the
cabin a longitudinal air for all which
means it's a bitter loss is a minimum
and therefore is much more dangerous to
get the loss of drop on it if you sit in
the same row rather than you get
different all but the model does not
completely rule out transmission to
people in different rows in this
simulation all these people around the
passenger are at risk
in fact those airborne cough drop 'lets
can move even farther down the cabin
if another passenger walks by the
individual that's coughing this second
simulation shows how that can happen
air movement created by the Walker can
carry the droplet down the aisle to a
completely different part of the plan
when you walk around there's a
possibility to get the disease or you
might not get it but you might bring
that it to your fellow passengers and to
make matters worse
cough droplets can land on all the
surfaces we touch losses on it didn't go
to you directly properly just go to the
tray table I'm rest even Heather Assad
is seated back in front of me but
despite all these models
dr. Chen says it remains hard for
scientists to predict exactly how a
virus would spread on a plane or whether
leaving a middle seat empty would
actually help protect us he uses this
reconstruction of a Boeing 737 flight
from Hong Kong to Beijing to illustrate
his point on March 15th 2003 a man
seated in 14e was carrying the SARS
virus during the flight 22 other
passengers and crew became infected
while data on this flight is incomplete
at least five people are known to have
died so majority of them just sit within
these three laws before and three rows
behind but you definitely see some of
those who sit a pretty far away you know
there's a two persons seated seven rows
in front of a decision that a person on
the other side we're also getting
impacted doctor Chen says this flight
has been widely studied but
epidemiologists still struggle to
explain exactly how the virus spread so
far through the length of the cabin so I
cannot guarantee that our animation is a
hundred percent scientifically proved
the results
what is your simulation tell us about
the effectiveness of blocking middle
seats two passengers I leave in the
middle seat open you all have a little
bit more social distancing but if you
look at our animation
isn't not that what a healthful so even
if middle seats were open in this
simulation it wouldn't do much to stop
cough droplets from reaching you still
according to dr. Chen an open middle
seat could be helpful if paired with
other precautions so if I were a
passenger and seat is open
I don't think I have a problem to go
there with my surgical mask surgical
masks can reduce the distance coughs
droplets travel from around six feet to
more like two feet and combined with an
empty middle seat they might actually
reduce risk
dr. Chen says an open middle seat could
help in another really important way
limiting the total number of people on
any given flight but that could present
a different problem when it comes to how
much our flights will cost the airline
industry operates on very thin margins
John Grant is an analyst at oag an
organization that tracks a global flight
data probably only 20 airlines in the
world consistently make a profit whoa
yeah well I realize that if you're
leaving every middle seat empty that's
30% of your capacity that you're not
sailing according to grant that could
mean a whopping 52% increase in average
ticket price for passengers will the
person sitting in New York today who
wants to fly to Florida next week be
prepared to pay 52 percent more no
honestly no no I'm particularly now
after nine weeks of lockdown less cash
at home etc etc listen the concern about
the middle seat makes sense until we
have a vaccine for the corona virus
flying is gonna be kind of scary but
well we can take precautions like
wearing a mask or leaving an empty
middle seat in the end we might have to
decide how much we're willing to pay for
a slight bump in
thanks for watching
that was an episode of Fox's first ever
daily show
it's called answered it's on a new
streaming app called squiffy and every
day we take on a question about what's
happening in the world right now from
the history of curfews to cicada season
so if you want to check out more all you
need to do is go to the link in the
description or download the kwibi app on
your phone and search for vox or
answered i'll be there every day
[Music]